our brain can potentially memorize 2.5
petabytes of information which is
roughly the equivalent of 3 million
hours of YouTube videos in order to use
some of that staggering capacity a
little more effectively when you learn
here are some tips that are based on
widely accepted research by
neuroscientists and learning experts
spaced repetition to maximize your
learning studies short but often
neuroscientists proved that synapses the
million billion connectors in your brain
that make you remember and understand
stuff grow mainly at night when you were
asleep this means that it is more
productive to study regularly with
sleeping breaks in between try it
practice something for 15 minutes every
day and you'll be surprised by your
progress within just weeks find your own
style while listening to the history
teacher
Tom scribbles images and jane finishes
one kilo of nuts some enjoy watching
videos over reading books others study
with friends and some like sitting in
silence among a million books everybody
is different good night's sleep sleep
and dreams are vital to processing and
storing new information a Harvard study
showed that students who had a good
night's sleep
remembered their study materials 35%
better than those who studied in the
morning to take a test in the evening
focus if you tend to procrastinate which
means that you tend to switch from doing
something hard like studying maths to
something easy like browsing the web
protect yourself from distraction one
way of doing this is to shut down your
mobile phone or go to a quiet place like
a library Pomodoro Technique
set a timer to 25 minutes when you focus
entirely on your studies when the timer
rings relax for five minutes if you want
to continue just set the timer again the
small breaks in between are relaxing and
motivating to keep going hard stuff
first do the things that are difficult
first because if you align most people
you have the strongest willpower in the
morning once you were done with the hard
stuff you will feel better for the rest
of the day and probably more motivated
to get other things done exercise
meditate and converse there are few
activities proven to grow your brain
however physical exercise regular
meditation and group conversations
apparently do exactly that
they lead to the creation of new neurons
inside your brain and therefore grow its
potential go places you can create
deeper memories of a subject by learning
in a richer environment that offers more
visual clues in an experiment two groups
of students had to remember random words
one group changed the classroom while
studying the other didn't the group that
studied in two different rooms one was
small and windowless the other big and
bright was 40% more likely to recall the
words later take fun seriously whatever
it is find a fun way to practice modern
learning science believes that positive
emotions are very important for
increasing your learning potential so do
yourself a favor and have a good time
space your studies in order to remember
things for a longer time
repeat the material in spaced intervals
facts or vocabularies for example a best
learned if you review them the first
time one to two days after the initial
study and then again after one week and
after one month 30% read 70% recite if
you have one hour to learn to recite a
poem or prepare for a speech spend 20
minutes of the time on studying the text
and 40 minutes on practicing to recite
this ratio usually leads to the best
results in the case of an emergency
put a glass of water next to you take a
sip whenever you lose it instant
self-test after you study finish up with
a quick quiz immediate recall in the
form of a test or a short summary on
what you've just learned can increase
retention by as much as 30% because it's
much harder for your brain to reflect
them to read that extra effort creates
deeper traces in your memory don't force
it
motivation is like hunger you cannot
force yourself to be motivated just like
you can't tell someone else to be hungry
so if you are not hungry right now don't
worry take a break and do something else
you
[Music]